[Music]
where each week we look for agreement on
a hot button issue that's dividing
opinion
tonight
after uvalde
how many scores of little children
who witness what happened
see their friends die
as if they're on a battlefield for god's
sake but the existence of evil in our
world is not a reason to disarm
law-abiding citizens and in god's name
are we going to stand up to the gun
lobby we all know they want
total gun
confiscation deer aren't running through
the
forest with kevlar vests on for god's
sake
is just sick
as always in the wake of these tragedies
the various gun control policies being
pushed
by the left would have done nothing to
prevent the horror that took place the
idea that an 18 year old kid
can walk into a gun store and buy two
assault weapons
it's just wrong we've been
afflicted
by a contagion of school shootings
carried out by
deeply evil violent and mentally
disturbed
young men
i am sick and tired of it
we have to act
and don't tell me
we can't have an impact on this carnage
how is the time to find common ground
the shots fired in texas rang out around
the world
there's empathy for america's children
after yet another lethal assault
but there's also fear that the slaughter
sets a pattern for others anywhere to
copy
our choice
should there be new controls on who gets
to hold a gun
or is there a better way to protect the
public
in the next 30 minutes two passionate
believers come head to head in the
search for common ground
[Music]
with me tonight lionel shriver the
journalist and author of we need to talk
about kevin
and ryan bussey former executive in the
firearms industry now a senior policy
advisor for giffords which campaigns to
reduce gun violence
let's start by agreeing that
in the unlikely event that america
were to decide to repeal the
constitutional rights of the citizen to
bear arms such a change would take many
years and a monumental
political struggle so it is pretty
unlikely to happen
let's also agree that nobody
certainly in this program is cavalier
about
the death toll
or about guns
and the thousands of people who have
been died or who have died or been
injured so what we're discussing today
is what can be done
in practice to lower the risk of another
uvaldi or sandy hook
or columbine
let me start with you ryan
um
what do you want to happen now
well i'm worried
about the role that gun radicalization
is playing in the destruction of the
democracy
and of course i'm very worried about the
spillover effects of that radicalization
which is a proliferation
of guns like the ar-15
into places where they shouldn't be
and
what i would like to see happen
of course i want to make things better
i don't believe that
there is a solution i often hear
you know folks
say that we have to work towards a
solution or we're going to find a
solution i don't believe that that's the
way complex democracies like the united
states work
what i would like to see happen is that
we start to make decisions that make
things marginally better
that we make decisions that make it
marginally more unlikely for uvalde or
buffalo or sandy hook or las vegas or
southern springs or like the point is
here i could go on we start to do things
that make it marginally
more unlikely that those happen
then keep doing things that make it
marginally more likely that they happen
so your point is direction of travel
just to be clear you spent
decades actually
in the firearms industry
uh essentially
you know someone unkind would say
peddling death
what has got you to the place where you
are now
i don't believe that i've moved much um
i still own guns
i still believe in firearms ownership i
hunt and shoot with my boys
i want to continue to do that
i also believe in responsibility
and i know that in a democracy like this
you have to balance freedoms
with responsibility and our balance in
the united states is now
way way out of whack so i'm here to
defend and advocate for
responsible gun ownership but i believe
that responsible gun owners if we want
to if we want to maintain
the freedoms that we have in the united
states then it's going to have to be
responsible gun owners that kick down
the door and say enough is enough
lionel shriver um ryan bussey is really
talking there about
the
owner rather than the gun itself and
your um book really dwells
much more on relationships and the
people
behind uh massacre
um
do you think that the kind of
improvement that ryan's talking about is
actually possible
i think it's possible to pass
legislation around the edges that makes
it
somewhat less likely
to
get hold of a gun
um
or for the
the wrong sort to get hold of a gun
i think that the effect is going to be
marginal at best i'm afraid
in defiance of
the uh very definition of this program
ryan and i are likely to agree on all
together too much
um
boring
it's okay it's not it's not a crime yet
to agree on television
um
i mean as as a as a writer and as a
person i'm ultimately more interested in
the individual motivation what goes on
in someone's head that drives them to do
something like this rather than i am
interested in public policy although i'm
also a journalist and public policy is
hardly foreign to me um
and i am broadly a supporter
of stricter gun control measures in the
united states
uh i
i worry that in this particular case
and therefore also in the case of
sandy hook uh that
both which was an earliest yes
eventually also the caliber
also slaughtered
not just children but elementary school
children in
quantity i sensed that
these
young men
tried to come up with the worst thing
they could possibly do
but that was the motivation
and that and that is very hard to
control
and well i want to come to talk about
about that
what's interesting is that straight away
yeah you do have common ground which is
that you both think that if there's
going to be any change it will be
incremental it'll be
baby steps it'll be tiny steps uh
if that's the case
starting with eulin why do you think it
has proven so
difficult
for uh politics in america even to take
the smallest step on this issue of of
gun control
well of course there are some states
there there have
there have been laws much more
restrictive laws passed
uh i i think the correlation between
those more restrictive laws and the
homicide results
is
modest
okay so
it's not i think it's really there
aren't there aren't laws out there in
fact ryan might might yeah i'm just i'm
going to come to you
on that point ryan why do you think it's
been so difficult to take even the most
basic
tiny steps that the two of you are
talking about
this and that's that's a very important
question because
unlike many other policy issues in the
united states
firearms and firearms radicalization
because of the way the nra has twisted
our politics
are at the very center of how
um
of how our politics works you cannot um
you cannot unentangle
wing radicalization and the sort of hell
no
ism of the nra that has infected all of
our politics in on every issue
and guns because it in my opinion i and
i assert in my book it all started with
guns this
nra figured out that they were in the
culture war business and that they would
use guns and the connect cultural
connection to guns to drive a culture
war we are now
at the apex of a culture war in the
united states and now we want to go back
and we want to try to adjust these sort
of
you know
around the edge policy debates but it's
so much larger than that because guns
are intertwined with the entire body
politic and the politics of the nra are
the politics of the united states now
the nra for those who don't follow this
closely the national rifle association
a very large very
rich actually historically
organization in the united states
funds uh or has funded
a lot of politicians and has it is said
great power um in washington dc but is
it your point ryan that what they are is
a bit more than
a group that
uh that supports um shooting sports but
it is actually much more a kind of
cultural association that takes a
a particular view of american life and
american freedom is that the point
you're making
it's precisely that it is a culture war
organization masquerading as a gun
rights organization the politics of the
country suffers and the politics of gun
issues and gun safety is collateral
damage and those kids are collateral
damage because of it
do you buy this lionel that this is
something driven by this this
organization particularly or ones like
it
um i don't think this individual case is
necessarily
an expression of a culture war problem
um
but
i think there is a culture war problem
that is
uh the issue of guns for
a certain segment of the population
which
i don't
especially identify with so i have to
use my imagination but
um
it's representative of of self-reliance
of a mistrust in
government in a mistrust in
law enforcement
it is
it's about
individual volition
dignity
the importance of being able to protect
yourself and your family
um
all of which is not terrible
right
and
and in fact it's very american
uh
you don't count on other people
you
you
make sure you can take care of yourself
and your own and you don't expect
someone else to do it for you and i'd
have to i'd have to say apropos culture
wars there are various um
there are various policies and
and um behaviors on the left that have
helped encourage people on the right to
feel unsafe
to feel that
even more intensely that no one out
there is going to protect them that
would include a completely out of
control situation in the border
the defund the police movement after
george floyd including all the um riots
looting and arson that followed that
that there was a huge uptick in gun
purchases uh during that period well let
me let me put that to you ryan i mean we
heard at the top of this
program
president trump making the case uh that
the problem here is not guns it's mental
health and so on and essentially he
characterized what
i think lionel's just been talking about
as the left-wing argument as in in a
sense um
giving him the license to to to be on
the side of americans and perhaps one of
the things
that's perhaps difficult for your
position is that the nra
isn't going about
giving out hundred dollar bills to
voters it is
putting out policies which people
actually vote for isn't the problem here
that actually the nra's
stance is popular in america
yes
um
i i think you
bring up good points i think i think
lionel did there are certainly truths to
the messaging around the air quotes here
defund the police um
i think was politically
atrociously unwise
um we do have problems at the border
ivaldi is not far from the border um
there are safety issues in the united
states as there are in every country
but the nra takes seeds of truth in all
of those
all of which are real issues
and magnifies them to such a degree
that they convince everybody
that easy easy easy access to guns all
the time is always going to be the
answer and by the way the left is trying
to destroy your livelihood
and
it's the degree to which
they turn it into hyperbole that is
creating this
there that's why every single time
any
there is any discussion about any
restriction whatsoever to make it
marginally harder for this kid to have a
gun the answer is hell no because the
the nra has set the course that we will
always support
weakening not strengthening weakening
gun laws when florida tried to do this
after the parkland shooting and florida
did pass it rick scott did the governor
of florida did pass raising the minimum
age to buy an ar-15 from 18 to 21 the
nra sued to block it
um so that's going to be they're going
to work to always make it easier okay uh
let me let me turn to
um your view about this line on you
right ly say you know you're
a writer largely of fiction or you're
famous for writing fiction um and you
inhabit
you know other people's
uh out minds and outlooks and so on
rather than uh worrying about public
policy but is there a point here
that uh
simply as some people want to do saying
that actually what we need to do is
focus on mental the mental health of the
shooters
in a way um
avoid the main problem
they're both problems and there's no
point in in deciding that you can only
tackle one of them
uh yes guns are too available
people who are not well can too easily
get hold of them and yes
uh
we have trouble with mental health and
it's it's under treated
and
[Music]
and
you know with the the guy in uvalde no
nobody knew
that he was that
disturbed
um but you know you just you need to
work on both fronts it's just
it's it's artificial to put them against
each other
one of the interesting one of the things
that's emerging from this conversation
for me is i i wonder if both of you are
saying something which is
it it's it's hard to say but let me put
it out there uh as i would say in the
united states
but this is the character of the united
states
that actually
this kind of thing is part of the
aspect of
the the culture that's been created
there one about freedom and so on and so
forth and that actually this is
inevitable is this part of being
american well
to make a rather fictional observation
it's very american right now
in that we have started to cultivate a
culture of self-pity
and i think that a lot of these
individual
shooters
feel terribly sorry for themselves and
um
you know i did a lot of research uh
before i wrote we need to talk about
kevin and
that was the most consistent element of
all of these incidents unless we forget
there were many many incidents like this
in school shootings in the 1990s even
before
the famous one in colorado
uh
they they
they they were externalizing a sense of
being victimized sometimes because they
were bullied sometimes because they
thought they were
superior and weren't being recognized
for being superior but in in any event
it was like it was one big you'll be
sorry and and and i'm afraid that that
this whole
um
lauding of victimhood
is
is creating more people like this rather
than fewer ryan does that resonate with
you in any
way hate to do this um on a show when
we're supposed to be
arguing over things we don't agree on
but you you guys don't have to apologize
for agreeing it's fine
yeah um
look
i if if you need to understand how
integral victimization is
to our political culture and then how it
spills over just listen to the arguments
after uvalde from the nra convention
that we just discussed and from trump
statements and then
other senators statements right it is
we will not let these the death of these
kids sacrifice you know be or or
infringe on our freedoms now the
liberals i told you they're coming to
get us they're coming to get our guns we
must be stalwart against them they are
they we are the victims here good
law-abiding americans are the victims
and in other words victimization
is at the very you cannot radicalize
people and you it's almost it's very
difficult to make
people do irrational things and evil
things if there is not some
victimization in the mix somewhere and
the nra and the political right in the
united states are really really good at
the victimization game well i would say
um i'd agree the uh the self-pity it's
not only on the left anymore it is on
both sides both sides feel terribly
sorry for themselves
we are not between the three of us um
as impressive characters as we are going
to change the united states tomorrow or
indeed uh impinge on american culture
let's go back to so
um
that's i think is really interesting
what you've both been saying
let's go back to some practicalities and
let's see if we can find some common
ground on things
that we might do and both of you as i
said earlier on
uh favor a kind of incremental approach
um
let's talk about some of the things that
have been suggested
uh stronger
background checks lionel what do you
think i'm fine with it
brian
no brainer should have been 20 done 20
years ago could you explain by the way
for
our audience exactly what that would
constitute i mean
what what what would happen if i for
example you know i'm in florida or i'm
in
wisconsin or somewhere and i want to buy
a gun
if you purchase a gun through a licensed
retailer so you go to a sporting goods
store or a gun store that is a federally
licensed dealer you must perform
what is called a next check nics check
or you if you fill out the federal form
as a 4473 form that does
a rudimentary federal criminal
background check on you
to just weigh your just basic general
suitability for owning a firearm you
must pass that it usually takes
two to three minutes it's not it's not a
hard thing to do
that
there are debates about how what the
percentage of gun sales are that adhere
to that law and rule it's high though i
i'm just gonna i'm just gonna throw a
number out here i don't i don't have the
data behind me i'm just gonna say it's
75 to 85 percent of gun sales um if not
more adhere to that law
there are the gun show loophole which
it's referred to in the united states
which the columbine shooters exploited
is a way in which you can get around
that without
doing a federal background check
and by that it's called a private sale
or a gun show if if a individual not a
licensed dealer goes to a gun show
or just on this you know advertisers on
the street like my name is bob and i
have a gun to sell you go purchase the
gun from him or at the gun show no
federal background check is done
and so
the the background the background check
fix bill would be to close that last
5 10 15 20 how we don't know because
it's not measured right when you do a
federal background check there's data
for it there is no data for these sales
ones that you don't and it's it's worth
saying that these uh gun shows are very
common very big and you know
i've driven into towns and there's a
there's a banner saying gun show today
and hundreds of people are going there a
quick thing uh red flags everybody
thinks that
uh
is talking about the idea that if some
you suspect somebody you know
of being unbalanced that you should be
able to report them to police or some
other agency for that
broadly but with caveat that i i think
that it does pose uh some civil rights
issues
brian
the red flag yeah and i think what yeah
i think lionel hits on an important
point here um
we are not going to make these things
marginally better without some sacrifice
with regards to freedoms and civil
rights there will be some infringement
um this there is this movement in the
united states called second amendment
absolutism which mean and they and they
literally say
shall not be in fringe right those are
words that are in the second amendment
of the constitution
and so many people say
nothing can be done that will make it
more difficult for me to purchase a gun
that is unconstitutional i don't believe
that but we should own up to the fact as
lionel does that there if we have
stronger red flag laws
there will be
some infringements around the edge like
we will make sacrifices i liken it to
and mistakes we'll make some mistakes
and
yeah we're going to put a red flag on
somebody that shouldn't have had a red
flag like it's it's going to it's just
impossible not to screw up in a country
of 350 million people it's it's going to
happen
the infringement
i like to say is like a school zone you
drive your car but you don't drive 90
miles an hour through a school zone okay
right that's an infringement but it's
one we accept
let me try one there's one third uh area
that people have been talking about
which i think
your expertise ryan would tell us
something about which is to restrict the
class of guns that are
available to citizens for example
making it impossible
for um the average citizen to buy a
semi-automatic weapon
not achievable
not advisable
probably not feasible in the united
states why not
well first off there's 450 million guns
in circulation
in a country of 350 million people
a huge part of those are i don't know
the percentage but maybe as many as half
or more are semi-automatic guns
um
further i i don't think that's not
politically achievable i don't think you
could get i don't think you could get 40
30 democratic votes for that um in fact
i doubt you could get 15. and so it's
just not achievable i'm not in favor of
that um
you know for a myriad of reasons not the
least of which i just don't think it
could ever happen
okay as i understand it um even during
the brief period that there was the
federal assault weapons ban in place
even that was not very effective because
the uh
as ryan i'm sure it's is better informed
than i uh
the
the manufacturer was fiddled uh
just enough that to get around the
definition of assault weapon which i
gather is
vague
if you want to understand the assault
weapons ban the gun that was used in
buffalo 18 days ago or whatever it was
was a gun that was legal and it was
manufactured during our assault weapons
ban that was an ar-15
it was called a post-ban gun meaning it
happened after the ban so that tells you
that was an ar-15 that was perfectly
legal during our assault weapons ban
do you do you see sort of how the idea
that all assault weapons were banned is
that simply not true it comes down to
definitions
okay
well look we're running run out of time
here and um i'm compelled to
uh say where i think we've got to i mean
there's a lot of common ground between
the two of you uh one thing which
actually i think is very important that
doesn't you don't hear a lot of which is
that you both think
we could get make some progress on this
if everybody just dialed it down a bit
and started stopped hurling
personalities at each other i think the
point that you've both made about
the character of
public discourse in the united states
uh resting on victimization or being
victimized uh
essentially the glamour of being a
victim is a really important one here
and we hear a lot of it
i'm left though at the end of this
conversation wondering whether it
generally is possible and whether what
we're seeing and this is a terrible
thing to say
um
whether
we are actually seeing something that is
native to the united states and
its character the idea of freedom the
way it thinks of civil rights and maybe
the problem here is not the individuals
but the problem is
america itself
but anyway this will carry on thank you
both very much
stay with us we'll all have we'll have
all the news from today coming up after
the break
[Music]
you